[Music]  you always find me the best toys  you can defuse it  stadium search team we found more  devices  signal could set this off  of course seismic charge primary rig to  block secondaries in the world  sophisticated very nasty this has cia  written all over it i know who did this  [Music]  i did what you cowards wouldn't  this is operational for dance has to be  destroyed  get me out of this chair  first we're gonna fix you  trust me  this is gonna hurt  16  twenty-three  either we have unfinished business  got reports of multiple explosions in  verdansk  sounds like a boy did a number on the  place get him up  we need to go  oh god  what have i done  shake it off it wasn't you  we're gonna finish what you started  we've got a job to do